und mit dieser schlagzeile ist
deutschland heute aufgewacht ein tank
rabatt soll kommen denn die hohen
spritpreise die drücken aufs
portemonnaie christian lindner der
finanzminister der kündigt jetzt sind
bild an er will dass sie wissen es zwei
euro pro liter zahlen müssen an der
tankstelle beim bezahlen sollen sie in
kürze vom staat einen rabatt bekommen
das ist die wichtigste nachricht für ihr
portemonnaie heute früh
denn wir schauen darauf auf diese kurve
hier die steil an zieht seit wochen
mittlerweile die aktuellen spritpreise
also einmal gelb diesel und weiß der
aktuelle benzinpreis wir gewöhnen uns in
diesen tagen daran dass diesel plötzlich
eben teurer ist als normalbenzin
232 ist aktuell der bundesschnitt beim
diese 1 liter bekommen sie dafür nur ein
liter diesel 232 und 227 aktuell der
bundesschnitt beim benzin wir fliegen
einmal durch das bundesgebiet haben
einmal uns die großen städte angeschaut
berlin hamburg frankfurt münchen köln
wie steht da der spritpreis sie sehen
überall dasselbe bild mittlerweile die
spritpreise sind überall gleichermaßen
teurer 226 228 2 28 29 usw gibt keine
großen unterschiede mehr in deutschland
deswegen sind wir noch mal ein bisschen
tiefer rein gegangen und zu gucken gibt
sowas noch wie die günstigste tankstelle
die teuerste tankstelle ja in der tat im
moment hier in niedersachsen den gab's
in der höchste preis für diesel und für
super
256 251 also sind wir mittlerweile
deutlich jenseits von zweieinhalb euro
pro liter benzin und diesel und ja
günstig ist das auch nicht in dresden
haben sie es heute früh noch für 2 15
und 2 17 den liter diesel bekommen also
das sind im moment preise über die man
sich anscheinend noch freuen muss 2 17
25 10 aktuell in dresden dass das
aktuelle spritpreis radar und da kommt
jetzt eben gerade recht was christian
lindner heute ankündigt in bild wir
schauen uns noch mal an wie er sich das
genau vorstellt also was hat er sich da
ausgedacht mit seinem tank rabatt er
verspricht dass
höchstens zwei euro pro liter angepeilt
werden unter diese grenze möchte er
wieder kommen von zwei euro pro liter
und dann soll das eben so laufen dass
man beim bezahlen an der kasse diesen
rabatt dann zurück bekommt hier sehen
wir es noch mal nein das ist die grafik
nicht schauen wir uns einmal an wie der
tank bohnes funktioniert beim bezahlen
soll man es dann zurück bekommen und der
tankwart der reicht dann die quittung
beim staat sozusagen ein und holt sich
hintenrum diesen rabatt vom fiskus
zurück darüber wollen wir jetzt sprechen
hier im studio patricia mit ihr
natürlich und bildpolitik chef jan
schäfer
ja ganz genau vielen herzlichen dank
high und bei uns jetzt bildpolitik chef
jan schäfer und wir wollen natürlich
herausfinden ob dieser plan uns allen
die tanken müssen überhaupt was bringt
oder ob das zu einer einzigen
zettelwirtschaft führt diese frage gebe
ich sofort an jan schäfer weiter schönen
guten morgen das klingt ja erstmal nach
dem plan ist wird zumindest was getan
als halten wir mal fest auf der anderen
seite die große sorge auch seitens der
tankstellen werden heute früh mit einem
betreiber aussprechen können ihr seid
das wird eine einzige zettelwirtschaft
sind wir dafür zuständig sind der ist
doch so einfach steuer senken runter
fertig aus ich glaube da hat beginnt so
ein bisschen das problem und das ist der
grund warum christian lindner jetzt
erstmal auf diesen tank rabatt setzt
eine steuersenkung ist nicht von heute
auf morgen umsetzbar so ein tank rabatt
ist deutlich schneller umsetzbaren dass
das was christa nennt auch möchte hat er
gesagt er möchte dass umgehend
umsetzen und deswegen kann es dieser
woche in dieser woche schon dazu kommen
dass nicht nur dieser tank rabatt
beschlossen wird sondern dass er
möglicherweise auch vielleicht sogar zum
wochenende schon eingeführt wird jetzt
gab es selbst in den eigenen reihen
innerhalb der regierung aber auch in der
fdp noch ein bisschen ja verwirrung was
ist das jetzt genau wie kommt sie jetzt
dazu nachdem christian lindner vor
sieben tagen hierbei bild läuft auch
ganz klar nein gesagt hat zu einer sprit
steuersenkung gestern abend auch thema
hierbei den richtigen fragen und der
fraktionschef der fdp wusste noch gar
nicht ganz genau was hat das alles zu
bedeuten
mit verlaub ich kann ihnen heute nicht
sagen welche maßnahme ist im detail sei
stehe aber rechtlich noch einmal den ton
von christian lindner vergangene woche
vor sieben tagen ganz genau zeigen dass
noch einmal ganz kurz zur erinnerung
also es gibt keine überlegungen derzeit
die steuern auf sprit zu senken nein
und jetzt gibt es aber diese
überlegungen richtig
es gibt überlegungen zu entlasten ob das
jetzt da ganz welche steuer ist genau
sein wird herr weise sie können mich
jetzt erst mal fragen nochmal ich will
am ende dass wir eine ampel das hinter
verschlossenen türen schnell diskutieren
damit wir schnell in eine entscheidung
und ein lokal wirkung heraus okay wir
haben fünf mal gefragt oder sogar 10 war
gefragt da kam dabei raus und dann eben
am abend tank rabatt das wort aber das
ist noch nicht abgestimmt das ist in der
regierung noch nicht abgestimmt in der
koalition nicht abgestimmt gibt es eine
möglichkeit dass das vielleicht gar
nicht kommt diese idee von christa linda
oder setzte das durch also unser
eindruck ist schon dass das abgestimmt
ist zumindest mit entscheidenden
personen eine entscheidende person in
der bundesregierung über der
bundeskanzler und nach unseren
informationen gab es dazu zumindest
kontakt präsentieren da würde so etwas
nicht machen ohne eine gewisse
abstimmung innerhalb des kabinetts auch
mit dem grünen koalitionspartner
was hier passiert ist das muss man ganz
klar sagen das ist jetzt schon ein
entlastungsbohrloch
plant und wenn wir zurückschauen eine
woche ungefähr dann stellen wir fest
dass ja die benzinpreise noch rund 30
cent niedriger lagen also da hat sich in
dieser woche sehr sehr viel getan das
hat sicherlich auch dazu beigetragen
dass man sowohl im
bundesfinanzministerium als insgesamt in
der koalition noch mal darüber
nachgedacht hat sagen wir müssen noch
etwas tun die bürger entlasten
bayerischen 37 tage und ungefähr 30 cent
ja und das würde abgestimmte mit den
grünen koalitionspartnern auch aber der
grüne wirtschaftsminister robert habeck
der ist jedoch nicht so richtig davon
überzeugt so scheint das auf jeden fall
am abend hat er das hier bei anne will
gesagt die bundesregierung arbeitet
permanent an
entlastungsmöglichkeiten wir werden die
in einem paket zusammenfassen und da ist
es jetzt nicht so sinnvoll einzelner
maßnahmen vor wegzuziehen ich würde
sagen sie müssen immer drei sachen
zusammenbringen erstens wir müssen
umfassend sein also die verschiedenen
energieträger und die verschiedenen
entlastungen in den blick nehmen
zweitens wissen sie immer kombiniert
sein mit effizienzmaßnahmen also weniger
energie zu verbrauchen
und drittens brauchen sie immer ein
marktwirtschaftliches signal es muss
immer sich lohnen weniger energie zu
verbrauchen und alle drei maßnahmen sind
jetzt in dem vorschlag von präsidenten
und nicht so abgebildet insofern glaube
ich darüber da kann man es noch ein
bisschen besser machen es war also nicht
mit ihnen abgesprochen
na ja es sind ja lauter vorschläge auf
dem markt und alle erzählen jetzt im
moment ein bisschen was ihnen gerade so
sinnvoll erscheint ich glaube klug ist
es mal sich zusammenzusetzen alles
systematisch aufzuarbeiten und dann die
richtigen entscheidungen zu treffen
was sagt also robert hare gern steht
fest wenn ich etwas ungewöhnlich dass er
sind direkt der kritik unter den
ministern kommt dann müsst ihr denken
moment mal ihr seid doch ein team aber
wenn er eine dem anderen dann schon
bevor es überhaupt losgeht sagt ja das
ist ja reden jetzt wieder sinn steht und
man muss mal gucken ob das überhaupt so
durchgeht falsches signal die grünen
haben ein massives problem
die ganzen klimaschutz bestrebungen die
ja ehrenwert sind werden aktuell
eigentlich muss man sagen von der
realität aufgefressen bei einem
benzinpreis von 230 240 250 zum teil
umgerechnet diese fünf mark die die
grünen ja ende der 90er auch immer
gefordert haben dass soll an liter sprit
kosten die sind jetzt realität geworden
bedeutet aber dass ganz ganz viele
pendler nicht mehr wissen wie sie sich
den weg zur arbeit leisten können
bedeutet wir haben das hier bei detlef
ja auch am freitag und in den tagen
danach bei bild immer wieder ganz
deutlich auch gemacht was beispielsweise
brummis die brummifahrer sagen der
brummifahrer verbands robert habeck ja
der mögliche vater verband jaaa vor dem
vor dem größten vor der größten
versorgungskrise seit 70 jahren wartet
der robert habeck mehrmals angeschrieben
hat robert habeck hat nie reagiert also
hier scheint es mir dann doch ein
realitätsverlust in gewisser weise im
grünen geführten wirtschaftsministerium
zu geben klar ist dass gehandelt werden
muss und die frage ist nur was sind die
anderen projekte die jetzt nicht
umgesetzt werden können dieser booster
den christian lindner platin entlastungs
booster beim tanken der kostet natürlich
geld nur mal angenommen der tank rabatt
würde 30 cent pro liter seien dann wären
das im monat ungefähr 1,5 milliarden das
ist ziemlich viel geld wenn es 20 cent
kommen wir so auf rund eine milliarde
entlastung für die autofahrer also das
ist viel geld und natürlich muss das
geld an anderer stelle eingespart werden
und das ist etwas was mutmaßlich robert
habeck jetzt ärgert weil er seine felle
davonschwimmen sieht einmal ganz schnell
zusammenfassen für alle die es noch
nicht ganz verstanden haben tank rabatt
klingt gut aber wie soll das praktisch
ablaufen ich fahre mit dem auto zur
tankstelle tankt eimer voll draußen
steht noch was ich 240 2 45 ich gehe an
die kasse bezahle und dann sagt mir der
tankwart 245 steht draußen dran aber
bezahlen musste nur noch 2 euro ungefähr
so so muss man sich das vorstellen ganz
genau man also es gibt einen so einen
festen tank rabatt geben das heißt es
gibt weiterhin auch den preiswettbewerb
zwischen den tankstellen ist jetzt nicht
so dass den tankstellen kein super
christian lindner will dass der
benzinpreis nur noch zwei euro kostet
dann nämlich 260 und krieg 60 die 60
cent die nicht mehr vom staat rücken
also ist es nicht es soll einen festen
tank rabatt geben wie gesagt der kann
bei 20 cent liegen vielleicht bei 25
schneider bei 30 cent und der wird an
der kasse direkt abgezogen das stimmt
also wenn man jetzt beispielsweise 50
liter zu 225 tanke ich nehme ein
beispiel dann wären das 112 euro
ungefähr so und jetzt kommt der rabatt
20 cent abgezogen pro liter bedeutet man
zeit 102 euro das wären also die zehn
prozent rabatt die bekommt man direkt an
der tankstelle man zeit nur die 102
statt der 112 euro und der tankwart der
muss sich dann am ende diese zehn euro
beim staat zurückholen das ist sozusagen
das prinzip mag ein bisschen
bürokratische fall aber für
wahrscheinlich eine sehr schnelle lösung
die praktikabel umsetzbar ist wir wollen
man gemeinsam schauen wie groß der frust
an der tankstelle ist unser mit
reportern als radweg der ist an einer
tankstelle in berlin mitte und kann uns
sagen ob dort immer noch voll getankt
wird oder ob der eine oder andere schon
nur noch mit halben tank umfeld und
abwarten will bis er vielleicht schon
nächste woche dann den tank rabatt
bekommen an
die leute müssen natürlich wie so viele
trotz dem tanken die preise sind hierbei
westfälin bei zwei euro 38 für den liter
diesel jetzt angestiegen das tut
wirklich weh die leute merken es im
portemonnaie aber sie müssen eben tanken
viele leute können eben nicht mit den
öffentlichen fahren oder mit dem fahrrad
weil sie waren transportieren müssen
oder weil sie eben so weite wege haben
auch in regionen wo eben der öffentliche
nahverkehr nicht gut angebunden ist und
deshalb müssen sie tanken wir haben um
gefragt bei den tankwagen selber die
glauben dass dieses rabattsystem doch
sehr kompliziert für sie ist und dass
sie letzten endes die zehn prozent
ungefähr die sie dann zurück holen lange
auslegen müssen und dass das im prinzip
eigentlich ein kredit ist in die
tankstellen an die kunden erstmal
zinslos weitergeben müssen und sie
erhoffen sich oder wünschten sich eher
dass die energie steuer runtergesetzt
wird eben auch nicht die mehrwertsteuer
weil die eben nur bei den privaten
ankommt und alle die gewerblich mit dem
auto unterwegs sind von der absenkung
der mehrwertsteuer nichts haben deshalb
die forderung der tank leute mit denen
ich gesprochen habe die energiesteuern
unter und ich habe auch ein betanken
denselben gesprochen und habe ihnen
heute die schlagzeile der bild -zeitung
gezeigt und das können wir uns gleich
mal anhören
los geht's ich
habe lindner hat versprochen wenn sie
jetzt tanken dass der preis unter zwei
euro wieder fall so wunderbar also wie
ich danke ihm sehr viel in die woche
dann weiß ich dann unter zwei euro soll
es dann kostet zwei euro da haben sie
sich vor einen kredit geben lassen dass
sie tanken gehen können kinder mehr
kredit weil schon alles verpassen das
auto
bild zeitung schon gelesen
christian linder verspricht jetzt den
großen tank rabatt vom radio wird und
was halten sie davon glaube ich nicht
dass der staat
kassiert so viel geld schon man steuern
und so weiter die werden darauf nicht
verzichten neben was nicht nicht
in großer menge herr lindner
spendiert jetzt den großen tank rabatt
das heißt sie tanken und kriegen einer
tankstelle dann das geld zurück wie
finden sie das ja das finde ich gut
so so ist
es gut wie hart war das jetzt die wochen
mit den hohen spritpreisen ziemlich ja
das ist zu teuer ist der drei jahren
geworden alles schon gesehen
christian lindner verspricht jetzt den
großen tank rabatt an immer glauben sie
daran
wenn lang glauben griechen die kirche
also das ist das jetzt mein mann mein
punkt aber wie hart hat sich der
spritpreis jetzt getroffen in den
letzten wochen ja zudem allen elend was
wir in unserem gewerbe haben durch
pandemie und andere faktoren
natürlich gibt es uns dass es an der
ruhigen grenze die hauptsache es ist
passiert was aber
fehlt mir auch die fantasie wie man dass
wir das wirklich einschränken kann wie
lange halten sie diese preise jetzt noch
durch über das kommt drauf an den pc
erscheinen schon staatliche hilfen
unsere situation ist längst über den
ruhigen grenze hinaus
ja danke hannes danke für deine stimmen
von der tankstelle es gibt noch skepsis
die meisten menschen wollen es noch
nicht recht glauben dass das wirklich
kommt aber der vorschlag liegt auf dem
tisch da kommt ja auch nicht mehr raus
der finanzminister steht relativ groß
heute in bild ja danke hannes danke
schön da bleiben wir natürlich weiter
dran